no they're not gonna happen
uh
it's good
here
two
how many minutes okay just two
is that all right
is
ready
good morning everyone
before i uh speak to the supreme court
extreme decision overturning roe
i want to comment on one piece of good
news
economic good news today
today the labor department reported that
we've added
372 000 jobs last month
372 000.
here's why it's important
our private sector has now recovered all
of the jobs lost during the pandemic and
added jobs on top of that
we have more americans working today in
the private sector than any day under my
predecessor
more today than any time in american
history
today
in the second quarter of this year we
created more jobs than any quarter under
any of my predecessors in nearly 40
years before the pandemic
think about that
at a time when our critics said the
economy was too weak or having already
added more jobs in my we had already
added more jobs my first year as
president of any president history we
still added more jobs in the past three
months than any administration nearly 40
years
now look i know times are tough
prices are too high
families are facing the cost of living
crunch but today's economic news
confirms the fact that my economic plan
is moving this country in a better
direction
the unemployment rate is near a historic
low of 3.6 percent
private sector jobs are at a record high
gas prices still way too high have
fallen out
days in a row
and this week we saw the second largest
single day decrease in gas prices in a
decade
we still have a lot of work to do i'm
not suggesting there's a lot more work
to do but i am suggesting we're making
significant progress the program is
working
now with the vice president secretary
becerra and deputy attorney general
monaco i want to talk about an executive
order i'm signing to protect
reproductive rights of women
in the aftermath of the supreme court's
terrible extreme and i think so totally
wrong-headed decision to overturn roe v
wade
in both formalized actions i announced
right after the
decision
as well as adding new measures today
let's be clear about something from the
very start
this was not a decision driven by the
constitution let me say it again this
was not a decision driven by the
constitution
and despite what those justices and
majorities said this was not a decision
driven by history
you've all probably had a chance to read
the decisions and the dissent
the majority rattles off
laws from the 19th century to support
the idea that roe was historic was a
historic anomaly because states outlawed
abortion in the 1880s toward the end
but that's just wrong the truth is today
supreme court majority
that is playing fast and loose with the
facts
even 150 years ago
the common law and many state laws did
not criminalize abortion early in
pregnancy which is very similar to the
viability line drawn by roe
but the dobbs majority ignores that fact
and the dobbs majority ignores that many
laws are enacted to protect women at the
time when they were dying from unsafe
abortions
this is the horrific reality that rose
sought to end
the practice of medicine should not even
suffice should not be frozen in the 19th
century
so what happened the descending opinion
says as clear as you can possibly say it
and here's the quote
neither in law nor facts nor attitudes
have provided any new reason to reach a
different result than roe in case he did
and that's has changed excuse me all
that's changed is this court end of
quote
all this change is this court
that wasn't about the constitution or
the law
it was about a deep long-seating
antipathy toward roe and the broader
right to privacy
as the justice wrote in their dissent
and i quote
the majority has overruled roe and casey
for one and only one reason because it
has always despised them and now it has
the votes to discard them end of quote
so what we're witnessing wasn't a
constitutional judgment it was an
exercise in raw political power
on the day the dobbs decision came down
i immediately announced what i would do
but i also made it clear
based on the reasoning of the court
there is no constitutional right to
choose only the way the only way to
fulfill and restore that right for women
in this country is by voting
by exercising the power at the ballot
box let me explain
we need two additional pro-choice
senators and a pro-choice house to
codify roe as federal law
your vote can make that a reality
i know it's frustrating
and it made a lot of people very angry
but the truth is this
and it's not just me saying it it's what
the court said
when you read the decision the court has
made clear
it will not protect the rights of women
period
period
after having made a decision based on a
reading of a document that was frozen in
time in the 1860s
when women didn't even have the right to
vote
the court now
now
practically dares the women of america
to go to the ballot box and restore the
very rights they've just taken away
one of the most extraordinary parts of
the decision in my view
is the majority rights that i quote
women it's a quote now from the majority
women are not without electoral or
political power
it is noteworthy that the percentage of
women who registered to vote and cast a
ballot is consistently higher than the
percentage of the men who do so end of
quote repeat the line women are not
without electoral and or political or or
maybe precise not and or or political
power
that's another saying you the women of
america can determine the outcome
of this issue i don't think the court or
for that matter of republicans who for
decades have pushed the extreme agenda
have a clue about the power of american
women
but they're about to find out in my view
it's my hope and strong belief that
women will in fact turn out in record
numbers to reclaim the rights that have
taken from them by the court
let me be clear
while i wish it had not come to this
this is the fastest route available
i'm just stating a basic fundamental
notion the fastest way to restore woe
row
is to pass the national law codifying
row
which i will sign immediately upon its
passage
on my desk and we can't wait extreme
republican governors
extremely public and state legislators
and republican extremists in the
congress overall
all of them have not only fought to take
away the right
our rights but they're now determined to
go as far as they can
now the most extreme republican
governors and state leaders have taken
the court's decision as a green light to
impose some of the harshest and most
restrictive laws seen in this country in
a long time these are the laws that not
only put women's lives at risk these are
the laws that will cost lives
what we're witnessing is a giant step
backwards in much of our country
already the bans are in effect in 13
states
12 additional states are likely to ban
choice in the next coming in the coming
weeks
and in a number of these states the laws
are so extreme
they've raised the threat of criminal
penalties for doctors and healthcare
providers
they're so extreme that many don't allow
for exceptions even for rape or interest
let me say it again
some of the states don't allow for
exceptions for rape or incest
this isn't some imagined horror
it's already happening
just last week was reported that a
ten-year-old girl
was a rape victim in height 10 years old
and she was forced to have to travel out
of the state to indiana
to seek to terminate the presidency and
maybe save her life that's last part is
my judgment 10 years old
10 years old
raped six weeks pregnant already
traumatized was forced to travel to
another state
imagine being that little girl
just i'm serious just imagine being that
little girl 10 years old
does anyone believe that it's ohio's
majority view that that should not be
able to be dealt with
or in any other state in the nation
a 10 year old girl should be forced to
give birth to a rapist child
i can tell you what i don't
i can't think of anything as much more
extreme
court's decisions aren't even received
by republicans in congress as a green
light to go further and pass a national
ban
a national ban remember what they're
saying they're saying
there's no right to privacy so therefore
it's not protected by the constitution
so left up to the states
and the congress what they want to do
and now my republican friends are
talking about getting the congress to
pass a national ban
in the extreme positions that they're
taking in some of these states
that will mean the right to choose
will be illegal
nationwide if in fact they succeed
let me tell you something
as long as i'm president it won't happen
because i'll veto it
so their choice is clear
if you want to change the circumstance
for women
and even little girls in this country
please go out and vote
when tens of millions of women vote this
year
they won't be alone
millions and millions of men
will be taking up the fight alongside
them to restore the right to choose
and the broader right to privacy in this
nation which they denied existed
in the challenge
from the court to the american women and
men
this is a nation
the challenge is go out and vote
for god's sake there's an election
november vote vote vote vote
consider the challenge accepted court
but in the meantime
i'm signing this important executive
order
i'm asking the justice department
that much like they did in the civil
rights area to do something
do everything in their power to protect
these women seeking to invoke their
rights
in states where clinics are still open
to protect them from intimidation
to protect the right of women to travel
from state that prohibits seeking the
medical attention that she needs to a
state to provide that care
to protect the women's right
to fda approved federal drug
administration approved medication
that's been available for over 20 years
the executive order provides safeguards
to access care
a patient comes into emergency room in
any state in the union
she's expressing and experiencing
life-threatening miscarriage
but the doctor is going to be so
concerned about being criminalized for
treating her
the delay treatment to call the hospital
lawyer who is concerned the hospital
will be penalized if a doctor provides a
life-saving care
it's outrageous
i don't care what your position is it's
outrageous
and it's
dangerous
that's why this executive order directs
the department of health and human
services hhs to ensure all patients
including pregnant women and girls
experience pregnant experiencing
pregnancy loss get emergency care they
need under federal law and the doctors
have clear guidance on their own
responsibilities and protections
no matter what the state no matter what
state they're in
the executive order protects access to
contraceptions that i'm about to sign
justice thomas himself said that under
the reasoning of this decision this is
what justice thomas said in his
concurrent opinion
that the court should reconsider the
constitutional right to contraception to
use contraception even among married
couples
what century
there used to be a case called
connecticut versus griswold which was
declared unconstitutional late 60s
it said a married couple
in the privacy of their bedroom
could not decide to use contraception
right now
on all 50 states in the district of
cumbria
the affordable care act guarantees
insurance coverage for women's health
services including including free birth
control
the executive order directs hhs to
identify ways to expand access to
reproductive health services
like iuds birth control pills emergency
contraception
and equally important this executive
order protects patient privacy and
access to information
which looking at the press assembled
before me probably know more about it
than i do i'm not a tech guy i'm
learning
right now when you use the search engine
or the app on your phone
companies collect your data
they sell it to other companies
or they even share with law enforcement
there's an increasing concern that
extremist governors
and others will try to get that data off
of your phone which is out there in the
ether
to find what you're seeking
where you're going and what you're doing
with regard to healthcare
talk about no privacy
no privacy in the constitution there's
no privacy
period
this executive order asks the ftc to
crack down on data brokers
that sell private information to extreme
groups or my views sell private
information to anybody
it provides private health information
it protects private health information
in states with extreme laws
the executive order strengthens
coordination at the federal level
it establishes a task force
led by the white house department and
the department of human services focused
specifically on using every federal tool
available to protect access to
reproductive health care
you know let me close with this
the court and its allies are committed
to moving america backwards with fewer
rights less autonomy and politicians
invading their most personal decisions
remember the reason of the decision
has an impact much beyond roe
and the right to privacy generally
marriage equality
contraception and so much more is at
risk
this decision affects everyone
unrelated to choice beyond choice
we cannot allow an out-of-control
supreme court
working in conjunction with extremist
elements of the republican party to take
away freedoms and our personal autonomy
the choice we face as a nation between
the mainstream and the extreme
between moving forward and moving
backwards
between allowing politicians to enter
the most personal parts of our lives
in protecting the right of privacy
yes
yes
embedded in our constitution
this is a choice
this is a moment the moment the moment
to restore the rights that have been
taken away from us
and the moment to protect our nation
from the extremist agenda
that is antithetical to everything we
believe as americans
now i'm going to sign this executive
order
protecting access to reproductive
healthcare
mr president what does prime minister
abby last night say about the security
situation in japan and can you give us
an update on your thinking about lifting
china tariffs
let me uh
i i tried to put a call in to
the present prime minister
and uh he was very late there at night
i'll be talking there
and i'm going to be
stopping to sign the condolence book at
the japanese embassy on the way to cia
um
this hasn't happened in japan
in decades and decades i i'm told we'll
go all the way back to the late 30s and
mid 30s
and it's a homemade
weapon
i've only seen a photograph of it the
just department is going to be going in
and giving me more detail later as they
find out the detail
but
the fact is that
one thing did strike my to give my
attention
that this is the first
use of a weapon to murder someone in
japan
and i think we have thus far have three
thousand
i've gone home to the numbers 688 or i
mean
between three and four thousand cases
they have one
one
one
and so uh um
but we're going to learn more
about as time goes on about motive about
the whole but japan fumio the present
prime minister
is a very solid guy
japan is a very very stable ally
and
we uh i i do not believe it's likely to
have but i don't know yet
likely to have any profound
destabilizing impact on japanese
security or japanese solidarity thank
you all so much
as well sir can you just give us your
thoughts on chinatown
would you recommend when to stop using
apps that track their health